I'm noticing just talking to you right
now and I'm reminded you have such a
great voice do you get a lot of
compliments on your voice you know well
I got I'm sure I probably had some
compliments on my voice
probably more before I took up another a
different career as a part-time opera
singer and then those comments kind of
dried up so people pray parties do you
like your voice I hate it you hate your
voice yeah oh that's when I when I hear
myself which I try never to do to me it
sounds like someone who's kind of
labored under heavy narcotics
[Applause]
for years and years I mean I think most
people don't don't like their voice and
I just could never stand it if I hear a
phone message I leave or something I
just or when I'm acting I always think
who is this person so right now when
you're talking to me there's part of you
that's stepped outside your body and is
saying I hate this guy no no oh good no
just that night a part of me is just
going because I don't have to listen to
myself now but if I went and watched it
I would just have to cover my ears right
now you're you're going to be playing
Blackbeard the pirate you mentioned this
to me backstage this is a TV project for
NBC here and be playing Blackbeard the
pirate are you going to use pirates
always have a pirate voice are you gonna
use a different voice you're gonna use a
pirate voice well when I when I was
talking to Frank from your show the
other day see I wasn't even aware that
pirates had a pirate voice and when he
asked me right was I going to do it in a
pirate voice I said that's a fantastic
idea what
that's ours now I'm gonna steal yeah uh
but I didn't even know that so I'm gonna
have to look at some pirate films which
I'm pretty sure I've never seen
oh no pirates never just I mean your
manner right now is is not you're not
pirate at all
you're very you can't can be like Oh
avast shiver me timbers you know you can
I can help you I sort of icon I love
that I'm giving you acting tips what's
even better is I may need this you're
gonna go and do this yes you're gonna do
this movie now and it's gonna be who's
the movie for it's for NBC oh good
[Applause]